[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to the line focus
Channel and my name is Paul today's
topic is the Hungarian language or
mahjong yes as it's called in Hungarian
Hungarian is not just another European
language there's nothing else quite like
it for starters it's not an
indo-european language so when you look
at a map and see that Europe's Hungarian
speaking areas are surrounded by
indo-european languages you have to ask
yourself how did Hungarian get there
most Hungarian speakers live in the
Carpathian Basin bordered by the
Carpathian Mountains to the north east
and south that includes not only around
ten million speakers in Hungary but also
in areas of the basin in neighboring
countries including Romania Serbia
Croatia Slovenia Austria Slovakia and
Ukraine the largest Hungarian speaking
minority is in north western and central
Romania where around 1.2 million people
speak it or around 6% of the country's
population
all of these Hungarian areas in the
Carpathian Basin were part of the
Kingdom of Hungary until 1920 when many
areas were ceded to other countries but
how did they get there in the first
place
Hungarian is a member of the you grip
branch of the Uralic language family
which originated in the vicinity of the
Ural Mountains which separate Europe
from Western Siberia the Uralic
languages include two main groupings
samoyedic which was the first group to
branch off from your Alec and
finno-ugric around 2000 BCE or maybe
earlier finno-ugric split into proto you
Greek the ancestor of the uuk branch and
proto Finnick the ancestor of the finnic
languages including Finnish and Estonian
proto you Greek remained a unified
language for more than a millennium
until Hungarian diverged from it around
800 BCE there's some debate about
whether the Hungarian ethnic group
the man jars originated to the west or
to the east of the Ural Mountains but at
some point around 2,000 years ago they
became nomadic in response to changes in
climate and landscape and began
gradually migrating towards the west
eventually reaching the Carpathian Basin
in the ninth century both while settled
near the Ural Mountains and while
migrating West the Magyar x' had
extensive contact with Turkic peoples
for instance the Magyar formed part of a
tribal alliance with turkic tribes
called own nogouda
meaning ten tribes which was based in
the northern Black Sea area this by the
way is the most likely origin of the
term Hungarian and its equivalents
hungary in latin in grey in greek and on
Gori in proto slavic after the own agora
alliance disintegrated they became part
of the Khazar Khanate a Turkic empire
covering much of the Caucasus region and
the Black Sea area for a time they
collected taxes from Slavic people on
behalf of the kazars until they became
politically independent from the kazars
in the year 830 this interaction with
turkic tribes and political entities led
to significant Turkic influence on the
Hungarian language it's hard to give an
exact count of the number of Turkic
loanwords in Hungarian but this lexicon
contains around 500 loan words from old
Turkic also the old Hungarian script
developed from the Orhan script the
Turkic runic script that was used by the
kazars in the 9th century the majority
reing out frequent raids in europe and
in the year 896 they crossed the
Carpathian Mountains under the
leadership of Otto pod and began
settling in the Carpathian Basin by the
Year 1000 a Christian kingdom was
established under King Stephen the first
under him
Hungarian began to be written in the
Latin alphabet but for some time the old
Hungarian script was used as well for
vernacular writing it was used by the
sake a Majora's until at least the 17th
century and since the early 20th century
it has undergone a revival to some
extent with limited use for symbolic and
cultural reasons Stephen the first also
made Latin the sole official language of
Hungary and it remained so until the
19th century
the old hungarian period the old
hungarian period conventionally begins
with the settlement of the Carpathian
Basin this is around the time of the
earliest fragments of written Hungarian
which date back to the 10th century and
are written in the old Hungarian script
isolated words written in the Latin
alphabet can be found dating back to the
mid 11th century and the oldest
extensive text is from 1190 to the late
12th century Hungarian has changed
relatively little since the old
Hungarian period but due to contact with
other languages and the assimilation of
other tribes it has absorbed words from
a variety of languages including German
and ironic and Slavic languages as well
as Latin and the Turkic languages we've
already discussed middle Hungarian the
middle Hungarian period began with the
printing of the first books in Hungarian
during much of this period the Ottoman
occupation of central and southern
Hungary took place and the Habsburg
Empire ruled the northern and
northwestern areas which likely brought
some additional Turkic specifically
Turkish and Germanic influences to the
language modern Hungarian in the 18th
and 19th centuries hungarian underwent a
language reform in order to standardize
it to make it more suitable for
literature and to make it more suitable
for the sciences they revived old
vocabulary used existing roots and a
fixation to create new words and
introduced some dialectal words on a
national level
in order to expand the vocabulary in
1836 it became the official language
alongside Latin and in 1844 it became
the sole official language of hungary
from 1867 to 1918 the kingdom of hungary
was part of the union of austria-hungary
in 1920 after austria-hungary's
involvement in the First World War the
Treaty of Trianon redrew the borders of
Hungary and assigned many of its areas
to neighboring countries based on the
ethnic composition of their populations
this resulted in the current situation
in which millions of Hungarian speakers
live outside of Hungary in neighboring
countries despite the fact that
Hungarian has ancient connections to
other Uralic languages today it's
similarities to them are not in
obvious and despite the fact that
Hungarian vocabulary has been widely
influenced by other languages the
borrowed words are mostly older words
that are further obscured through
compounding and a fixation for example
the word Goomba meaning mushroom this
was borrowed from old Slavonic Goomba in
modern Bulgarian it's Guba and in Super
Mario Brothers it's Goomba but this word
can also form a compound word with this
word here Sanna meaning species Goomba
sada means fungus to make it plural we
add a k' Goomba fadec then there might
be a case ending Goomba fayek at now
it's in the accusative case you may be
thinking hey that beginning part is
still recognizable to speakers of
Bulgarian yeah maybe but in other Slavic
languages that root is not so commonly
used anymore or has changed more than it
has in Bulgarian like in Slovak it's
kuba the main point I'm getting at is
that a lot of the loan words in
Hungarian are not immediately
recognizable but anyway that brings us
to the most important question what's
Hungarian like Hungarian is an
agglutinative language meaning that
words are made up of a linear sequence
of morphemes that each contribute a
piece of meaning to the word so let's
start with this word virus meaning city
for the plural we add book virus okay
meaning cities and for words ending in a
vowel you just add for the first person
singular possessive we add boom a virus
ohm meaning my city now let's make it a
location of Irish album means in my city
this here by the way was the definite
article which we'll look at a little
later so you can see how we start with
the root word and add suffixes to it to
add meaning but the suffixes are not
always exactly the same for example GEB
meaning pocket for this word the plural
would be G Bek my pocket hmm my pocket
in the plural Asha beim in my pocket
hmm them in my pockets Asha Ben Ben so
what's up with all the EES instead of
the O's and the a as we saw in the first
word well
Hungarian features something called
Val harmony this means that the vowels
which appear in suffixes depend on the
vowel in the final syllable of the word
so the suffix is in the first example
virus are in harmony with the vowel oh
and the suffix is in the second example
Jeb are in harmony with the vowel e the
exact vowel used also depends on the
type of suffix we can also see vowel
harmony and agglutination in hungarians
verb conjugations the base form of the
verb meaning to write is eed for regular
verbs these verb endings here are added
to verbs with one of the following
vowels in the final syllable the base
form of the verb meaning to drive or to
lead is visit these verb endings here
are added to verbs with one of the
following vowels in the final syllable
either short or long e the base form of
the verb meaning to sit is good these
endings right here are added to verbs
with any of these vowels in the last
syllable but there's more these
conjugations you see here are indefinite
conjugations transitive verbs in
hungarian have different conjugations
depending on whether the object is
definite or indefinite let's take the
verb to write in a book means I write or
just yolk because Hungarian is pro drop
meaning the subject pronoun can be
dropped
Iroquois lammott I write something here
okay turn yet I write a book here we
have a direct object and edge is an
indefinite article yo ma can you vet
I write the book o is a definite article
and Edom is the definite conjugation
Hungarian verbs also have past tense
forms both definite and indefinite ones
with almost no exceptions
there is no separate form for future
tense but the future can be expressed
using the infinitive of a verb plus the
present tense of the verb folk knee so I
will write a book is evening so location
Yvette and I will write the book is
initial mecon yet there are also
numerous prefixes which can be added to
verbs some of which add a new shade of
meaning to the verb and others which
completely change the meaning
of the verb before we saw the verb booth
which means to sit as in you are
currently in a seated position if you
want to express the meaning of sit as in
sit down you add the prefix net low and
it can also mean to serve like in this
phrase meaning to serve a prison
sentence
Burton bent at each level to say sit up
in other words to stop slouching you say
fellow Bell means sit in sometimes used
for getting into a car
el means to sit still or to sit away
from the prefix L means away this word
also means blow over or subside and
before we saw the verb visit meaning
drive or lead and it also means to
conduct electricity leva set means drive
down like from a hill or from the
Capitol to the countryside but it also
means deduce Bevis it means to drive
into and it also means introduced in
other words to put into practice fair to
visit means mislead or deceive and there
are numerous more the way that these
prefixes alter the meanings of words is
not always consistent so you can't
always just put two and two together but
sometimes that works there are also a
couple types of suffixes that can be
attached to the verb to change its
meaning but at depending on vowel
harmony or dot that show causation for
example visit means drive or lead visit
that means make someone drive and after
that you can add verb endings to
conjugate it like rosetta tink we make
someone drive and that's the indefinite
form by the way visit that Duke is the
definite form visit that you Daniela's
all taught
this means we make daniel drive the car
led is the instrumental case suffix
which is used here to show who is being
caused to do something it's basic forms
are vowel and well depending on vowel
harmony but when attached to a noun
ending in a consonant the v assimilates
to the final consonant resulting in
gemination a double consonant as is the
definite article before we saw the
ah but when the noun begins with a vowel
then the form oz is used the two at the
end of our tote is the accusative case
ending which is used to indicate the
direct object cases one of the most
notorious aspects of the Hungarian
language is its system of cases which
are attached to nouns there are 18 cases
though some people will say there are
more look at these tables for the noun
meaning car
this looks pretty intimidating however
most of these case endings function in a
similar way to prepositions in English
except that they are after the word in
other words they're like postpositions
take the dative case form o to knock
this means to the car
the instrumental case o dov'è would mean
by car the terminated case o to egh
would mean something like as far as the
car for example if you were going to
walk until you reached the car the
innocent case o deulim would mean in the
car the ablative case O'Doyle would mean
away from the car and so on
so thinking of them as postpositions
rather than case endings might make it a
little less intimidating and it may look
like there are separate forms for plural
nouns but there really aren't the plural
forms simply have the plural suffix cup
and then the case endings are added
after that the only tweak to that is the
double consonant in the instrumental
case that we saw before as well as in
another case called the translated case
unlike in many other languages cases
only affect nouns not adjectives or
articles in addition to cases there are
also possessive suffixes and these can
be used together with various case
endings as otome my car and to express
this fully we need to use the definite
article as autumn bum Valley Oak I am in
my car as Oh towed your car as a talukas
Otto Doyle I'm walking away from your
car or maybe it would be as Auto Tasha
Toluca I'm walking away from your car
with the emphasis on your car Hungarian
word order is not set in stone when
something appears before the verb it is
emphasized so by moving the noun to the
beginning we are placing emphasis on it
the verb prefix or pre verb el meaning
away also moves out of the way when
something else is placed in front of the
verb to emphasize it it's like the main
verb is handing the emphasis over to
whatever comes before it but if there's
a pre verb in the way the main verb
can't pass the emphasis but if the pre
verb gets out of the way then there's
nothing blocking the emphasis from being
handed over since these pre verbs can be
split from the main verb they can be
referred to as Co verbs let's add an
adverb to the sentence as she italic
without auto lotion this means I'm
walking slowly away from your car with
no particular emphasis now lashauwn
sheitel Collazo todo this means I'm
walking slowly away from your car with
the emphasis on slowly when there's an
explicit subject placing it before the
verb places emphasis on it if there's no
pre verb in the way Micah aceite so
totally Jean Michel is walking slowly
away from your car this sentence has no
particular emphasis but let's get the
pre verb out of the way Mike O'Shea that
lashonna so toto Michael is walking
slowly away from your car here the
emphasis is on Michael because it comes
right before the verb Michael Essien
shayla's Oh toto
Michael is walking slowly away from your
car again the emphasis here is on
LaShawn slowly because it comes right
before the verb this position right
before the verb is the most emphatic if
the verb comes at the beginning before
an explicit subject then the verb is
emphasized
but for this sentence the meaning
wouldn't really make sense a couple of
notes on Hungarian phonology and
orthography in terms of phonology and
orthography Hungarians not exactly the
simplest language out there there are 14
vowels this includes seven pairs of
short and long equivalent with the acute
accents indicating long vowels one of
the immediately noticeable features is
the double acute accent to show the long
equivalents of the vowels with umlauts
there are also 30 consonants for a total
of 44 letters in the Hungarian alphabet
but some of the consonants consist
of two or three orthographic letters
these consonants with a Y or palatalized
consonants and there are these others
see s equals Chuck DS es equals j SZ
equals sir and zs equals J in addition
to palatalized consonants another common
phonological and orthographic feature is
gemination lengthened consonants that
are represented by double consonants in
writing if you see a sentence that
contains double consonants consonants
followed by Y and multiple acute accents
umlauts or a double acute accent then
you're almost certainly looking at
Hungarian let's look at one final
sentence in Hungarian and break it down
nan way ok hashmat matter betameche
Caviezel boom the sentence means I'm not
hungry
because I already ate lunch at a cafe
word for word it's no I am hungry
because already I had lunch ah cafe in
first we see the negation word nem this
word doesn't change and you just put it
before the part of the sentence that you
want to make negative there are other
forms of negation as well but this is
the basic way in indicative sentences
next we see Valley Oak which means I am
this ending book is a typical present
tense ending meaning I with it's vowel
harmonizing with this a vowel oo but
this verb is a rather special one in a
regular verb removing oak would give you
the third-person singular present tense
form but for this verb odd is the second
person singular and the third person
singular is Vaughn it also has a
different past tense stem would and it's
also the only Hungarian verb with its
own inflected future tense form other
verbs express the future using two verbs
like we saw before
a Heche is the word for hungry the
singular form of this word is always the
same and is never inflected for gender
or case Abaddon is the first person
singular past tense of the verb meaning
to have lunch Abaddon which has the base
form
Aveda them is the first person singular
past tense inflection and vowel harmony
determines that it's them not thumb this
is the indefinite conjugation but for
the first person singular past tense the
definite and indefinite forms are
actually the same edge is the indefinite
article Caviezel boom is the word for
cafe with the in Esav case ending bond
in other words it's like a post position
meaning in and it's worth noting that
this ending is bond not been because
it's in harmony with the Oh
at the end of Chavez Oh as you can
probably see Hungarian is quite
different from any indo-european
language and it's different from any
other language in Europe it's a glutton
ative grammar and it's noun cases which
functions somewhat like postpositions
are somewhat similar to other
finno-ugric languages but there are also
differences and it contains much less
finno-ugric vocabulary than you might
expect but despite being different
hungarian is really not as complicated
as people make it out to be the noun
cases aren't that hard to wrap your head
around if you think of them like
postpositions vowel harmony isn't that
hard to get used to because there are a
limited number of variations and
indefinite and definite conjugations
work very logically it just takes some
time to get used to them and other
aspects of hungarian are quite simple
for example there's no grammatical
gender at all and adjectives and
articles are not inflected for case
which makes dealing with the cases much
simpler the main point I'm getting at is
that after digging into hungarian a
little bit just enough to make this
language profile i've come away with the
impression that it's not as complicated
as i had been led to believe so if
you're interested in the hungarian
people or the hungarian culture or the
country of hungary then don't be scared
to start learning the hungarian language
as well the question of the day to
native speakers of hungarian what
language or languages do you think share
the most similarities with hungarian and
to learners of hungarian what aspects
the language have you found most
challenging and what has been more
straightforward be sure to follow Lange
focus on Facebook Twitter and Instagram
and once again thank you to all of my
patreon supporters especially the
amazing ones right here on the screen
who are my top tier patrons so many
thanks to them as always and to everyone
else thank you for watching and have a
nice day
[Music]